des émissions bonjour oui bonjour je
vous appelle par rapport à Tout le monde
en parle et donc là tout le monde dit
Thierry Ardisson il est extraordinaire
je suis désolé mais moi personnellement
je trouve que c'est vraiment un gros
alors autre promo la télé
vous êtes revenu sur Canal après deux
ans d'absence tu vois car
on peut revenir sur Canal après deux ans
d'absence la preuve oui oui à part
l'argent et les filles faciles qu'est-ce
qui vous a incité à revenir sur Canal
parce qu'on avait le sentiment d'avoir
une bonne idée avec le service
après-vente des émissions donc on a un
système un petit peu plus ouais voilà le
but du service après-vente des émissions
c'était les spectateurs qui appelle pour
donner leur avis ou se plaindre des
émissions il dirait quoi s'ils
appelaient pour parler de tout le monde
en parle à votre avis
on peut
écouter faudrait se mettre en condition
de service après-vente déjà il faudrait
des téléphones
parce que quelqu'un a des téléphones
il y a des je crois qu'on a été piégés
[Applaudissements]
service après-vente des émissions
bonjour oui bonjour monsieur je vous
appelle à propos des vins
qui est cette personne bah écoutez elle
a joué dans la ferme alors elle a fait
quel animal elle a fait la poule ou la
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
pour tout le monde
service après-vente des émissions
bonjour oui bonjour je vous appelle par
rapport à Tout le monde en parle et donc
là tout le monde dit Thierry Ardisson il
est extraordinaire je suis désolé mais
moi personnellement je trouve que c'est
vraiment un gros
c'est parfait je sais très bien moi je
le regarde le dimanche
ça passe après le Rans Ferrari
les enfants c'est comment canal après
deux ans d'absence donc c'est bien c'est
oui non ça fait plaisir
c'est
nous c'est nous le plus c'est nous parce
que c'est vrai que 2 ans sans faire de
télé ou c'est on va pas le cacher
c'était un peu dur le fait de revenir
attention
je te préviens tu vas devenir un
clochard on l'a vécu
aussi alors moi tout va bien
pour l'instant on va chez toi
en place c'est un peu de pas durer et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu